regardez ce qui arrive à gâteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes à toulouse
[Applaudissements]
voilà
le jour
[Applaudissements]
non
je t'attends
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas vrai
[Musique]
besoin de booster les chéris mais celle
là là là là attendez attendez on et
réseaux de sécurité lâche de shay pas du
tout les chez nous à vous de faire ce
que j'aime et nous on va partir sur
satan les deux minutes on fait attention
pendant parce que malik a failli faire
très mal
le site ne bouge plus nogueira piquet jr
de sécurité jamais demandé à toutes les
personnes du public et toutes les
chroniqueurs de ne pas bouger parce que
je vous dis le soleil monosol c'est un
enfer même l'état bon jeu mais je n'ai
pas bougé aussi que personne n'a bougé